- What did you have to learn to love
about yourself when you were a kid,
like other than like your eyebrows
or weird like aesthetic things,
but anything like personality-wise.
I feel like a lot of creative people
were always kind of introverted at first.
- I think we all have our
insecurities and for me,
body image was a really big thing
and I've been very vocal and
open about my experiences
with eating disorders and just how, now,
my fiance is so supportive
and it's like finding
new ways to feel centered
and not reverting back to old ways.
And it's, I think it's so admirable
for both of you to be
such strong advocates
of talking about things
that a lot of people think
are taboo or shameful.
It's like, we all just need to say
that we all go through these
things and we're not crazy
and no one of us is alone, you know?
And I just think that we all
have those little things.
- Yeah, and I also think that were always,
I literally just was talking
about this yesterday with someone.
I was like, "Well, I'm
always like working on
"being the better version
of myself, for the bet,"
you know what I'm saying?
There's always gotta be
a better, I don't know,
I like progressing or whatever.
So, I always think
- No for sure, for sure.
- That therapy is so good for everybody.
- It's one of the good things
now about social media.
There's so many bad things, I think,
that make us feel isolated
about like technology and social media,
but actually to that point,
like breaking that taboo,
the more people reach out and say,
"Hey, I'm feeling this way."
And then you feel that swell of love,
whether you're in the public eye or not,
to say, like "I've been there.
"I know what you feel like."
There's actually been a
really amazing community
of people to say, like "I got you"
and that's been a cool thing to see.
- Yeah.
- That's amazing, Josh,
because that's actually the community
that I've found on my
social media platforms
which inspired me to write my book
because all these people
were reaching out,
talking about their insecurities
and prefacing it by saying,
"Oh, but you're an actress.
"You probably have no idea
what I'm talking about."
And I'm thinking, "I'm an actress
"and I know 100% what you're talking about
"and let me tell you why."
And it just inspired me
to then share my story
because none of us are
above sharing our stories.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah.